10 km lang und 350 meter hoch war das
ist wirklich ein enormer hohlraum den
ein internationales forschungsteam
darunter einem der größten
antarktisgletscher aufgespürt hat die
kaverne war wohl ursprünglich mal mit
achtung 14 milliarden tonnen eis gefüllt
und das town geht weiter allein das
abschmelzen des zweites gletschers
könnte den weltweiten meeresspiegel um
sage und schreibe 65 zentimeter anheben
und nicht nur das er fungiert als eine
art stöpsel und verhindert damit eine
unbeschreibliche katastrophe doch das
drama nimmt seinen lauf was genau hat es
mit dem gigantischen hohlraum unter dem
eis auf sich und wie katastrophal ist
das abschmelzen des gletschers wirklich
die antworten jetzt bei pixum science
fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann und
nur dann verpasst er nicht herzlich
willkommen auch bei diesem thema muss
ich noch mal ganz dringend hier drauf
aufmerksam machen weltweite demo am 15
märz gegen den klimawandel sei das for
future geht da unbedingt hin
seid dabei wir müssen dringend etwas
ändern weil so geht es nicht weiter
es droht sonst eine unglaubliche
katastrophe und damit sind wir auch
schon beim thema es geht um den zweites
gletscher in der westlichen antarktis
der etwa so groß ist wie der us
bundesstaat florida
schon jetzt ist das tauen dieses
gletschers für etwa vier prozent des
globalen meeresspiegelanstiegs
verantwortlich und das drama hat wohl
gerade erst begonnen denn der jetzt neu
aufgespürte gewaltige hohlraum unterhalb
des schelfeises sorgt für große
beunruhigung die größe dieser höhle ist
kaum zu beschreiben sie ist etwa so hoch
wie der eiffelturm und ihre grundfläche
entspricht der halben fläche des
chiemsees und nicht nur dass dieser
gigantische hohlraum enthielt wohl mal
etwa 14 milliarden tonnen eis doch der
großteil davon ist alleine in den
vergangenen drei jahren geschmolzen
schon seit längerer zeit haben fachleute
diesen gletscher und der region
drumherum besonders kritisch im blick
denn klar ist dass hier besonders viel
eis verloren geht doch die jetzt
ausgewerteten radaraufnahmen
überraschten das forschungsteam selbst
denn mit einem extrem großen hohlraum
der in solch beunruhigende ausmaß wächst
hatten die fachleute nicht gerecht
eine erklärung gibt es aber schon
wärmeres mehr wasser dringt am end
bereich des gletschers zum eis vor und
sorgt dafür dass es von unten abschmilzt
und das nicht ohne folgen die entstehung
eines solchen hohlraum es beeinflusst
dann auch die weitere zukunft des
gletschers dazu der nasa-forscher pietro
mio da mehr wärme und wasser unter dem
gletscher gelangen schmilzt er schneller
die analyse zeigt erschreckendes denn
das schelfeis das auf dem wasser im
vorderen bereich der höhle liegt
schmilzt schneller als es modelle
vorhersagen zudem schmilzt schneller als
das eis das an jedem anderen ort in der
antarktis bislang vermessen wurde
warmes salziges wasser unterspült den
gletscher teil und eismassen vom
landesinneren rutschen nach wenn der
zweites gletscher komplett abschmilzt
würde dies schätzung zufolge einen
anstieg des meeresspiegels um 65 cm
bedeuten
doch als wäre das nicht schon
katastrophal genug wird es bei diesem
szenario wohl nicht bleiben denn der
zweites gletscher hat zusammen mit
seinem nachbarn dem pine island
gletscher eine unfassbar wichtige
funktion für die westantarktis denn
beide stabilisieren weitere gletscher
und bilden quasi eine art stöpsel der
die eismassen daran hindert in den ozean
dahinter zu gelangen
passiert das doch würde dies laut nasa
einen anstieg des meeresspiegels achtung
von 2,4 metern bedeuten
manche experten experten gehen sogar von
einem anstieg von dreieinhalb metern aus
schon in einem zeitraum von 100 jahren
könnte dieser prozess ablaufen das ist
nicht gut nun stehen dringend weitere
untersuchungen an
damit wir die prozesse an den gletschern
besser verstehen können dazu eric trikot
von der university of california
um die auswirkung dieses netz auf den
meeresspiegelanstieg in den kommenden
jahrzehnten vorherzusagen muss man
verstehen wie das meer in abschmelzen
die aktuelle untersuchung legt jedoch
nahe dass die wechselwirkung von
gletschern und polar [ __ ] deutlich
komplexer sind als bisher gedacht denn
bislang ging man davon aus dass solche
riesigen kavernen unter den gletschern
eher statisch sind und eben nicht so
rasant wachsen
doch schon jetzt steht jedenfalls fest
schuld am steigenden meeresspiegel ist
der klimawandel und er wird nicht nur
den menschen den entfernten regionen wie
indonesien ägypten oder thailand das zu
hause nehmen auch wir in deutschland den
niederlanden und belgien werden
betroffen sein und schon jetzt passiert
in teilen der welt der reinste horror
durch den anstieg des meeresspiegels
sind im pazifik schon jetzt mindestens
acht komplette insel verschwunden für
immer betroffen sind inseln der
salomonen an inselstaat in der südsee
und auch mikronesien ein inselstaat im
westlichen pazifischen ozean
in beiden regionen liegt der anstieg des
meeresspiegels weit über dem
durchschnitt dort wurde nämlich sogar
ein jährlicher anstieg von 1,2
zentimetern gemessen abgesehen davon
dass ihre heimatinsel
eine große historische bedeutung für
ihre bewohner haben sind die menschen
dort gezwungen alles aufzugeben
auch orte an denen wir gerne urlaub
machen sind dabei zum beispiel die
dominikanische republik kuba die
seychellen oder die fidschi-inseln es
gibt studien die prognostizieren dass im
jahr 2100 ein fünftel ein fünftel der
weltbevölkerung klimaflüchtlinge sind
also mehr als eine milliarde menschen
werden nach europa und alle anderen
höher gelegenen gebiete kommt
überflutete küstenregionen sorgen diesem
szenario nach für eine massenflucht ins
landesinnere in dem dann nutzbare
flächen viel zu knapp werden die
nahrungsmittel produktion wird dann
extrem schwierig wir hier in deutschland
müssen an großteil der niederländischen
bevölkerung aufnehmen schon jetzt kommt
das land dem immer schneller steigenden
meeresspiegel auch in der nordsee nicht
mehr hinterher und durch die
weggeschmolzen eismassen in der arktis
verdunstet dort immer mehr wasser was zu
den starken regenfällen in den letzten
jahren geführt hat die folge sind höhere
pegel des rheins der von der landesseite
von der landseite zeitweise ungeheure
wassermassen in die niederlande bringt
der klimawandel ist in vollem gange
und das viel schneller als gedacht
klimawandel war es der mensch brandneues
video bei raum zeit wird der zukunft
unbedingt draufklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran